Hi there, Shankar here, we're in the middle of our summer series called U2.0. This week's episode comes from our early days of Hidden Brain. It looks at who comes up with great ideas, and what we can do to have more of them. Adam Grant was teaching his first class at the Wharton Business School when a student came up to him with an interesting proposition. He says, I've got this big idea. Three friends and I are going to start an online business, and we're going to disrupt an industry. Do you want to invest? But from what Adam could see, this group of friends wasn't doing so well and getting
你好，我是尚卡尔，我们正处于名为“U2.0”的夏季系列节目的中期。本周的节目选自《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）早期内容。它探讨了谁能提出伟大的想法，以及我们能做些什么来获得更多这类想法。亚当·格兰特在沃顿商学院教授他的第一门课时，一名学生带着一个有趣的提议来找他。他说：“我有一个宏大的想法。我和三个朋友打算创办一家在线企业，我们要颠覆一个行业。你想投资吗？”但从亚当的观察来看，这群朋友在实现那个宏大想法的过程中表现得并不好。
that big idea off the ground. Six months go by, it's the day before launch, they still don't have a functioning website. The whole business is a website, that's literally all it is. And so I obviously passed on the investment. The name of the company? Warby Parker. They were just saying the most innovative company in the world by fast company and they're worth over a billion dollars, which is why my wife handles all her investments now. I'm Shankar Vedantanthan and this week on Hidden Brain, Originals, how to spot one, how to be one.
六个月过去了，距离发布还有一天，他们甚至还没有一个可用的网站。整个业务就是一个网站，字面意思就是这样。所以我显然放弃了投资。这家公司的名字？沃比派克（Warby Parker）。他们刚刚被《快公司》杂志评为全球最具创新力的公司，市值超过十亿美元，这就是为什么我妻子现在负责她所有的投资。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，本周的《隐藏的大脑》原创节目，探讨如何发现原创者，以及如何成为原创者。
We bring you my conversation with Adam Grant. He's a professor at the Wharton School of the University of Pennsylvania, and he's the author of the new book, Originals, How Non-Conformist Move the World. I asked Adam what the Wabby Parker episode had taught him about the qualities of innovators. They often procrastinate, and that's how they incubate ideas. What parents can do to nurture originality in their kids, their parents focus more on values than rules.
我们为您带来我与亚当·格兰特的对话。他是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的教授，也是新书《原创者：非同凡响的人如何改变世界》的作者。我问亚当，沃比派克的故事让他学到了关于创新者素质的什么。他们经常拖延，而这就是他们孕育想法的方式。父母可以做些什么来培养孩子的原创性？他们的父母更注重价值观而非规则。
And the downside of marching to the beat of your own drum. One of the risks is you have everybody marching in a different direction. Looking back now, Adam, looking back if you could go back and talk to the old Adam, what would you tell that Adam? I would say that I was totally wrong about what it takes to be original. I think of original people as the non-conformist who drive creativity and change in the world. And I would say they often procrastinate, and that's how they incubate ideas. They feel the same fears and doubts that the rest of us do. They just manage them differently. They hate taking risks.
以及特立独行的负面影响。风险之一是每个人都朝着不同的方向前进。回顾过去，亚当，如果你能回到过去和那个老亚当谈谈，你会告诉他什么？我会说，关于成为原创者所需的条件，我完全错了。我认为原创者是推动世界创造力和变革的非同凡响的人。我会说他们经常拖延，而这就是他们孕育想法的方式。他们和我们其他人一样，也会感到恐惧和怀疑。他们只是以不同的方式处理这些情绪。他们讨厌冒险。
And they have lots of bad ideas, and that's how they get to the good ones. I have to say though, it's possible that when someone sits in an idea for six months and they're an online company and they don't have a website ready to go the day before launch, it is also possible that they could turn out to be a gigantic failure. You're just trying to make me feel better
他们有很多糟糕的想法，而这就是他们获得好想法的方式。但我必须说，当一个人把一个想法搁置六个月，而且他们是一家在线公司，在发布前一天还没有准备好网站，那么他们最终也可能成为一个巨大的失败者。你只是想让我对我的决定感觉好一点，对吧？你会投资吗？我不会。是的，我的意思是，当然，他们可能会失败，但我应该注意到的是，他们也具备了原创者通常带来的所有其他特征。所以很多时候你会发现，原创者并不是拥有最深厚专业知识的人，而是拥有最广泛经验的人。
about my decision, right? Would you have invested? I would not. Yeah, I mean, of course, it's possible that they would fail, but what I should have paid attention to is they also met all these other characteristics that originalists tend to bring to the table. So a lot of times you see that originals are not the people with the deepest expertise, so the people with the broadest experience.
尼尔的背景之所以如此出色，是因为他曾在发展中国家销售眼镜，并免费赠送眼镜，试图帮助那些视力不好的人改善生活，使他们能够工作。他接触到了各种事实，了解到眼镜的制作成本远低于西方世界的垄断企业。他们也非常善于质疑现状。
And what was so great about Niels' background is he had been selling glasses in the developing world and also giving them away to try to help people who couldn't see get their lives in a place where they could work. And he had all sorts of exposure to the fact that you can make glasses a lot more cheaply than the monopolies here in the Western world were doing it. They were also really good at questioning the status quo.
这是成为原创者的标志。很多人只会说，你知道，眼镜的价格就是这样。医生给你开了处方，事情就结束了。他们加起来有60年的戴眼镜经验。但有一天，创始人之一戴夫突然说，为什么它们这么贵？
And this is a hallmark of being an original. A lot of people would just say, you know, glasses cost what they cost. Your doctor prescribes them and that's the end of it. And they had 60 years of combined experience wearing glasses. But suddenly one day, one of the founders Dave said, why do they cost so much?
它们已经存在800年了，竟然比iPhone还贵？这说不通。一旦他们对此进行了研究，他们发现他们可以做很多事情来降低价格。我认为这是一个他们即将腾飞的信号。在你的书中，你发现作家兼诗人T.S.艾略特、谷歌联合创始人拉里·佩奇，以及电话。
Like they've been around for 800 years and they're still more than an iPhone? That doesn't make sense. And once they did research into it, they found out that they could do a lot to lower the price. And I think that was a sign that they were going to take off. In your book, you find that the writer and poet, T.S. Eliot, Google's co-founder, Larry Page, and the phone.
都有一些共同点。当他们有机会一头扎进某件事、冒大风险时，他们实际上会规避风险并犹豫不决。你能谈谈这一点吗？因为这与我们认为真正的原创者行为方式背道而驰。确实如此。我认为发生的情况是，他们害怕失败，就像你我一样。
All have something in common. When they have an opportunity to dive headfirst into something, take a big risk, they actually hedge their bets and hesitate. So can you talk a little bit about that? Because that runs counter to the way we think that people who are true originals actually behave. It does. I think what happens is they are afraid of failing, just like you and I might be.
起初，当他们有一个新想法时，他们不确定它是否会成功。他们不知道自己是否能以此为生。所以T.S.艾略特，诗歌并不是最赚钱的职业。他做银行职员来支付账单，并给自己作为诗人进行原创的自由。我认为拉里·佩奇和谢尔盖当时都处于这样一种境地：看，我们想做的是，我们有很多伟大的想法。他们当时是斯坦福大学的博士生，想出了谷歌的点子。
And at first, when they have a new idea, they're not sure if it's going to succeed. They have no idea whether they can support a livelihood based on it. So T.S. Eliot, poetry is not the most lucrative career. He works as a bank clerk to cover his bills and give himself the freedom to do something original as a poet. And I think Larry Page and Sergey were both in the position of saying, look, what we want to do is we have lots of great ideas. They were PhD students at Stanford at the time they came up with the idea for Google.
他们确实想到了，他们认为搜索很糟糕，于是编写了一个算法，通过页面链接到其他页面的方式来判断页面的受欢迎程度，从而做得更好。他们并没有将其视为职业。他们只是说，我知道一种更好的方法来做这件事，然后他们就把它建成了。他们还没有准备好迈出那一步。他们有愿景，你知道，继续创造知识。并完成了他们的博士学位，毫无疑问他们的父母也希望他们这样做。是的，我可能仍然希望他们这样做。
They were and they thought search was bad and they wrote an algorithm to do it better based on pages linking to other pages, being an indication that a page was popular. And they didn't see that as a career. They just kind of said, I know a better way to do this and they built it. And they weren't ready to make the leap. They had visions of, you know, continuing to just create knowledge. And finished that PhDs, as doubtless their parents would I wanted them to do. Yeah, I maybe still want them to do.
等待迈出那一步的巨大优势在于，你不会感到将其推向市场的压力。如果他们依靠这个谋生，他们会说，我们需要把这个搜索引擎推出去。我们需要现在就把它推出去。因为他们没有这样做，所以说“让我们把它做好”要容易得多。再说一次，当你看到人们在地下室和车库里做的事情时，这是无数人都在做的事情。
Great advantage of waiting to make that leap is you don't feel the pressure to rush it to market. If they were depending on this for their livelihood, they would have said, we need to get this search engine out there. We need to get it there now. And because they weren't doing that, it was much easier to say, you know, let's get this right. And again, I mean, when you look at what people are doing in basements and in garages, this is what countless people do.
我的意思是，他们有日常工作。他们是会计师。但他们在车库或地下室里玩耍，试图建立一些新的东西。是的，我们为电影之夜准备好了，对吧？他在卖掉耐克之前，在车后备箱里卖了七年的鞋子，同时做着会计的日常工作，他在那七年里学到了很多东西，增加了他成功的机会。那么，是什么让你在“我还在修修补补”和“我真的要开始行动了”之间做出切换？对于那些只是拖延、思考、计划并在车库里无休止地工作的人，以及那些说“我会在车库里工作前两、三、四年”的人，会发生什么？
I mean, they have a day job. They're working as an accountant. But they're playing in that garage or that basement and trying to build something new. Yeah, we're dead okay for a film night, right? He sold shoes out of the trunk of his car for seven years, working a day job as an accountant before he finally started Nike, and he learned a lot in those seven years that increased his chances to succeed. So what makes the switch between the point of which you're sort of saying I'm still tinkering versus I'm actually going. What happens to the people now who just procrastinate and think and plan and endlessly work in their garages and the people who say I'm going to work in my garage for the first two, three, four,
五、六年，但最终我还是会去试水。我认为发生的情况是，对失败的恐惧被对“未能尝试”的恐惧所取代。所以，如果你有一位伟大的外科医生，或者你相信你正在制作的电影会改变世界，那么在某个时刻，你会从担心后悔让自己出丑，转变为后悔从未尝试过。正如你所知，心理学家在后悔方面始终发现，很多人在当下害怕冒险，但从长远来看，我们最大的遗憾是不作为，即我们没有抓住的机会。
five, six years, but eventually I go out and test the waters. I think what happens is the fear of failing gets overtaken by the fear of failing to try. And so if you have a great surgeon or you believe that a film you're making is going to change the world, then at some point you shift from worrying about regretting, making a fool of yourself, to regretting, never taking a chance. And as you know, that's what psychologists consistently find about regret, that a lot of people are afraid in the moment of taking the risk, but that in the long run our biggest regrets are in actions, the chances we didn't take.
我说，是的，它可能会失败，但这仍然比“未能产生影响”要好。你在书中发现的一件事让我非常着迷，那就是很多时候，发起新企业、新职业或新社会创新的人实际上并没有选择自己去做，而是被其他人征召的。是的，我对此感到非常惊讶。米开朗基罗受命绘制西斯廷教堂，他抬头看着天花板，心想我怎么可能做到这一点？他很害怕，所以他逃到了佛罗伦萨。然后他被劝说回来，并被说服尝试一下。
And I say, yeah, it might fail, but that's still better than failing to matter. One of the things that you find in the book that I found very intriguing is that very often, people who launch new ventures or new careers or new social innovations don't actually choose to do it themselves, but they are drafted by other people. Yeah, I was so surprised by this. Michelangelo got commissioned to paint the cysteine chapel and he's looking up at the ceiling thinking how in the world could I do that? And he's terrified, so he flees to Florence. And then he sort of gets coaxed back and talked into giving this a shot.
马丁·路德·金不想领导民权革命。他最初的梦想是成为一名牧师，然后是大学校长。他出现在一次会议上，被一致投票推选为领导这场运动的人，基本上是被拖进去的。所以你发现，人们往往在被置于某种程度上不熟悉的职位时，能够胜任这一角色。确实如此，我认为这有时使他们在这些领导角色或创新方面如此有效，因为他们已经花了几个月或几年的时间来酝酿这些想法，当有人把他们拉到聚光灯下时，这些想法已经孵化出来了。
Martin Luther King doesn't want to lead the civil rights revolution. His first dream is to be a pastor and then a college president. And he shows up at a meeting and he's been voted unanimously to lead this movement and basically dragged into it. And so what you find is often people then rising to the occasion when they sort of placed at this position that's in some ways an unfamiliar position. It is, and I think this is sometimes what makes them so effective at these leadership roles or at innovating that they've spent months or years stewing on these ideas and they've hatched by the time that somebody pulls them into the spotlight.
这就引出了一个问题，当你有一个组织并想尝试获得最优秀的人才时，也许该做的不是发布招聘启事并询问谁来申请，而是去征召那些表面上看起来并不理想的人。我认为这很有道理，你知道，原创性正在各种意想不到的地方酝酿。所以很多时候，作为领导者，我们所做的是扼杀它，而不是试图释放它。
And that leads to the question, when you have an organization and you want to try and get the best talent, maybe the thing to do is not sort of put a job at out and say who applies for it, but actually to be drafting people who might not on the surface seem like the ideal fit. I think there's something to be said for that, that, you know, originality is brewing in all sorts of unexpected places. And so often, as leaders, what we do is we stifle that as opposed to trying to unleash it.
有很多事情可以做，试图弄清楚，好吧，谁是有能力为这个组织带来真正新想法的人？为什么我们没有听到他们的声音？安静的作者苏珊·凯恩喜欢说，谁是最会说话的人和谁有最好的想法之间没有相关性。这是一个得到广泛支持的实证发现。我很乐意在识别那个沉默的少数群体并给他们发言权方面做得更好。
And there's a lot that can be done to try to figure out, OK, who are the people that are in a position to bring really new ideas into this organization? And why aren't we hearing from them? Susan came, the quiet author, is fond of saying that there's zero correlation between who's the best talker and who has the best ideas. And that's a widely supported empirical finding. And I'd love to do a better job identifying that silent minority and giving them the floor.
你必须问这如何反映在我们的政治体系中，亚当，在政治体系中，说话和赢得公开辩论的能力往往是赢得公职不可或缺的一部分？是的，你知道我希望看到的是一个基于领导技能而非演讲能力的政治体系。所以我想知道的是，哪些政治家将成为最有效的决策者，谁将提出最好的战略愿景，谁在处理冲突方面有专业知识？我们现在看不到这一点。而且我认为我们也寻找那些想要挺身而出的人。我们寻找那个举手的人。
You have to ask how this reflects on our political system, Adam, where the ability to speak and win a public debate is often integral to winning public office? Yeah, you know what I would love to see is a political system that's based more on skill in leading than it is on speaking. So what I want to know is what politicians are going to be the most effective decision-makers, who's going to come up with the best strategic vision, who has expertise in handling conflict? We don't see that right now. And I think we also look for people who want to step forward. We look for the person who puts up their hand.
我们寻找那个说“我是最合格的人”的人。当然，听到主动性是件好事。听到动力是件好事，但这可能并不是这份工作的最佳人选。是的，我最兴奋的人是那些对这份工作完全不感兴趣的人。我不知道我们怎么能让他们上台。
We look for the person who says, I'm the most qualified person. And of course, it's nice to hear initiative. It's nice to hear drive, but that might not actually be the best person for the job. Yeah, the people that I'm most excited about for are the ones who have no interest in the job whatsoever. I don't know how we get them on the stage.
对，因为当然，拥有最引人注目的演讲并不一定能让你有资格知道当叙利亚发生内战时该怎么做。我想投票给那个愿意反驳自己的人，对吧？并承认自己错了，因为，你知道，有些人称之为反复无常，我认为这是一种启蒙。我的意思是，在你书中的人物中，
Right, because of course, having the most compelling speech doesn't necessarily qualify you to know what to do when there's a civil war in Syria. I want to vote for the candidate who is willing to contradict him or herself, right? And admit to being wrong because, you know, some people call that flip-flopping, I think if it is enlightenment. I mean of the people in your book whom you look at,
有多少人有那种演变，如果可以这样说的话，无论他们尝试什么，如果不奏效，他们就尝试别的东西，如果不奏效，他们实际上并不僵化，而是实际上乐于适应。我认为这是成为原创者的标志之一，就是思维足够灵活，能够承认“我知道这是错的”或“这是一个坏主意”。亚伯拉罕·林肯在担任总统时，最初并不打算废除奴隶制，他担心这会摧毁联邦。
how many of them have that kind of evolution if you will, whether sort of try something, it doesn't work, they try something else, it doesn't work, and they're not actually rigid in their thinking, but they're actually open to being adaptable. I think that's one of the hallmarks of being original, is being flexible enough in your thinking to admit you know this was wrong or this was a bad idea right abraham linkin when he came into the presidency he was initially not going to abolish slavery he was afraid that it would destroy the union
他在那个决定上痛苦了六个月，才最终签署了《解放黑人奴隶宣言》。他是个反复无常的人，对吧？这是这个国家历史上最重要的行为之一。托马斯·爱迪生，进入创新领域。爱迪生在试图开创灯泡先河时，研究了各种失败的发明。
and he agonized for six months over that decision for finally signed the emancipation proclamation he's a flip flopper, right? That's one of the most important acts in the history of this country. Thomas Edison, to go to the innovative domain. Edison worked on all sorts of failed inventions while he was trying to pioneer the light bulb.
他发明了一个会说话的玩偶，非常令人毛骨悚然，不仅吓坏了孩子，也吓坏了成年人。一个会说话的玩偶。一个会说话的玩偶。看到这张照片，我做了噩梦。所以它真的会动嘴，然后发出声音？是的。是的，这是一个非常早期的机器人。
He invented a talking doll so creepy that it scared not only kids, but adults too. A talking doll. A talking doll. I've had nightmares looking at the picture of this. And so it actually moved its mouth and words came out? It did. Yeah, this is a very early sort of free robot.
他试图，你知道，开采，他试图用磁铁开采铁矿。他试图用失败的技术保存水果。他必须愿意承认这些想法行不通，才能转向那些行得通的想法。但这意味着的一件事是，区分伟大与平庸的，不一定是伟大的人只有伟大的想法，而是伟大的人只是比平庸的人有更多的想法。我认为这正是故事所在，对吧？最伟大的原创者是失败次数最多的人，因为他们是尝试次数最多的人。
He tried to, you know, mine, he tried to mine iron with magnets. He tried to preserve fruit with failing techniques. And he had to be willing to admit that these ideas were not working out to move on to the ones that did. But one of the things that this implies is that what distinguishes the great from the ordinary is not necessarily that the great only have great ideas, but that the great simply have many more ideas than the ordinary. I think that's exactly the story, right? The greatest originals are the people who failed the most because they're the ones who tried
如果你在许多不同的领域研究这一点，并不是原创者的命中率比同行高。只是他们产生的数量更多，这给了他们更多的多样性，以及尝试新事物的更好机会。所以巴赫、贝多芬、莫扎特，他们平均来说在典型的作品中并不比同行好，但他们每个人都创作了超过600部，在某些情况下超过1000部不同的作品，其中一些是真正的杰作。当你审视莎士比亚的作品时，你也发现，在莎士比亚创作他最伟大的杰作的同时，他也写了一些他最糟糕的作品。
the most. If you study this across lots of different domains, it's not that originals have higher hit rates than their peers. It's just they generate more volume, which gives them more variety, and a better shot at something new. So Bach, Beethoven, Mozart, they were not on average in a typical composition better than their peers, but they generated over 600 each, and in some cases over a thousand different compositions and a few of those were true masterpieces. When you looked at the works of Shakespeare, you also found that at the very same time Shakespeare was writing some of his greatest masterpieces, he was also writing some of his greatest duds.
是的，你听说过《温莎的风流娘儿们》吗？《雅典的泰门》呢？如果莎士比亚今天在这里，他会想让我们知道，在那段时间里，他还写了《哈姆雷特》和《麦克白》。那么，当同一个人坐下来写剧本，或者同一个人坐下来做发明时，怎么会同时产生天才和垃圾呢？第一，因为我们很多人爱上了我们的第一个想法，而那些是最传统的。通常你必须剔除熟悉的，才能得到不寻常的，但很多人从未达到那些后来的想法。第二件事是，真的很难
Yeah, have you heard of the Mary wives of Windsor? What about the Tumon of Athens? If Shakespeare were here today, he'd want us to know that around that time, he also wrote Hamlet and McBeth. So what explains this when the same person is sitting down and writing plays, or the same person is sitting down and doing inventions, how is it that they're producing genius and crap at the same time? One because a lot of us fall in love with our first ideas, and those are the most conventional. Often you have to weed out the familiar in order to get to the unusual, but a lot of people never get to those later ideas. A second thing is, it's just really hard
判断你自己的想法。我们大多数人对自己想出的想法过于乐观。而且很多时候他们需要把一堆想法放到世界上，他们可以得到反馈并找出真正有意义的东西。我想知道莎士比亚是否也是如此。如果我们真的让莎士比亚在写完《温莎的风流娘儿们》和《麦克白》一年后坐下来，
to judge your own ideas. Most of us are way too positive on the ideas we come up with. And oftentimes they need to put a bunch of ideas out in the world, they could feedback and find out what actually made sense. I'm wondering if the same thing is true of Shakespeare. If we actually sat Shakespeare down the year after he wrote
有没有可能他会告诉我们，你知道，《麦克白》还可以，但《温莎的风流娘儿们》才是杰作。你知道，这在原创者中太常见了。我显然不能告诉你莎士比亚会说什么，因为他没有回答我的采访请求。但是，你知道，你一直看到科学家们这样，
the Mary Wies of Windsor and Macbeth, is it possible that he might have told us, you know, Macbeth, it's okay, but the Mary Wieser Winsor, that's the masterpiece. You know, this is so common among originals. I can't tell you what Shakespeare would have said, obviously, because he didn't answer my interview request. But, you know, you see this with scientists all the time,
他们引用率最低的作品往往是他们认为最伟大的作品。还有贝多芬。贝多芬以伟大的自我批评者而闻名，然而他在预测哪些作品会成为他最大的热门和最大的失败时，却相当离谱。我今天的嘉宾是亚当·格兰特。他是沃顿商学院的教授。接下来，我们谈谈谁有机会成为原创者，以及父母如何培养孩子的这种素质。我想稍微看看可能被称为“原创性的阴暗面”的东西，
that frequently their least-sided works are the ones that they think are the greatest. And Beethoven. Beethoven was known as a great self-critic, and yet he was pretty far off the mark in predicting which of his pieces were going to be his biggest hits and his biggest flops. My guest today is Adam Grant. He's a professor at the Wharton School. Coming up, we talk about who gets the chance to be original and how parents can foster this quality in their kids. I want to look a little bit at perhaps what might be called the dark side of
或者也许“阴暗面”不是正确的词。更多的是原创性的好处在我们的社会中分配不均。是的，我认为这是一个巨大的悲剧，我们看到女性和少数族裔群体在有原创想法时不太可能大声说出来。我是谢丽尔·桑德伯格，我去年写了一篇关于这个的专栏文章，叫《女性发言》。我们涵盖了一堆证据，包括我进行的一些研究，表明当男性大声说出来时，他们会因此受到奖励。
originality, or maybe the dark side is not right the right word. It's more that the benefits of originality are not distributed equally in our society. Yeah, I think this is a great tragedy that we see both women and racial minority groups being less likely to speak up when they have original ideas. I'm Cheryl Sandberg and I wrote an op-ed about this last year called speaking wall female. We covered a bunch of evidence, including some of some studies that I ran, showing that when men spoke up, they were rewarded for it.
而当女性大声说出来时，要么她们几乎没被听到，通常某个家伙会走过来窃取她们想法的功劳，要么她们被认为太咄咄逼人，违反了我们对女性的这种社区化、关怀的刻板印象。我认为这些刻板印象导致许多女性退缩，因为她们害怕反弹。我认为这些刻板印象导致许多女性退缩，因为她们害怕
And when women spoke up, either they were barely heard, and usually some dude, like, sort of wanders in and steals credit for their idea, or they were judged as too aggressive and violating these communal, caring stereotypes we have of women. And I think those stereotypes lead a lot of women to hold back because they're afraid of backlash. And I think those stereotypes lead a lot of women to hold back because they're afraid
反弹。我认为我们需要更多的组织，我认为世界上的人们需要检查他们的偏见，并乐于接受女性和少数群体将他们的想法带到桌面上。但你不得不怀疑，有多少伟大的想法根本没有被提出来，因为人们对谈论它们感到犹豫。是的，我认为我们错过了世界上大多数的原创想法，不是因为人们没有创造力，而是因为你拥有的想法和你分享的想法之间存在差距。
of backlash. And I think that we need many more organizations and I think people in the world to check their biases and be receptive to both women and minority groups bringing their ideas to the table. But you have to wonder how many great ideas are not being put on the table at all because people feel hesitant to talk about them. Yeah, I think we're missing out on the majority of the original ideas in the world, not because people aren't creative, but because there's a gap between the ideas you have and the ones
如果你回到我们之前谈到的关于想法的数量、创造力、关系的想法，你知道，历史上显然充满了男性在某些领域完成大部分原创工作的例子。这主要是因为他们有自由去研究很多想法，而女性主要从事育儿工作，她们很难让自己的想法被听到。在书中，你谈到了出生顺序，无论你是否有哥哥姐姐或弟弟妹妹，可能会在你的冒险意愿中发挥作用。
that you share. And if you go back to this idea about the volume of ideas, sort of creativity, relationship that we talked about earlier, you know, the history is obviously full of examples of men doing the majority of the original work in certain fields. And that's largely because they had the freedom to work on lots of ideas, whereas women were primarily working on childcare and they had a hard time getting their ideas heard. In the book you talk about the idea that birth order, whether you have older siblings or younger siblings, might play a role in your willingness to take chances.
你能谈谈那项工作吗？这非常有争议。我想我从未见过社会科学的另一个领域有更多的竞争结果。但有一系列研究表明，长子往往是稍微传统一点的成就者，而次子更倾向于挑战现状并做一些有点原创的事情。而且，看看这个。你看看300多对打职业棒球的兄弟。
Can you talk about that work? This is wildly controversial. I don't think I've ever seen another realm of social science with more competing results. But there are a series of studies suggesting that firstborns tend to be slightly more conventional achievers, whereas laterborns are more inclined to challenge the status quo and do things that are a little bit original. And get this. You look at over 300 pairs of brothers who played professional baseball.
这样你就可以在家庭内部进行测试。你会看到，弟弟尝试盗垒的可能性比哥哥高出10倍以上。那么为什么会这样呢？我认为弗兰克·萨洛威的一个流行解释是，这与利基选择有关。很难通过比哥哥姐姐更聪明或更强壮来脱颖而出。
And that way you get to do the test within families. And you see that younger brothers are more than 10 times more likely to attempt to steal a base than their older siblings. So why is that? I think that one factor that the popular explanation from Frank Zulloy is that it's about niche picking. That it's hard to stand out by being smarter or stronger than your older siblings.
他们在学术和运动方面有明显的优势。所以你所做的是寻找其他脱颖而出的方式，其中之一就是冒险或有创造力。但我认为故事的另一部分是，父母往往给后出生的孩子更多的自由。训练人们成为原创者的方法是什么？在公司、组织和家庭中鼓励原创性的方法是什么？让我们从家庭方面开始。
They have a clear advantage academically and athletically. So what you do is you look for other ways to stand out, and one of those is to take risks or be creative. I think the other part of the story, though, is that parents tend to give more freedom to their later born children. What is the way you train people to be original? What is the way you encourage originality in a company and an organization and a family? Let's start with the family side of it.
如果你研究一些美国最原创的建筑师，并将他们与技术精湛但创造力较差的同行进行比较，在创意建筑师的家庭中发生的一件事是，他们的父母更注重价值观而不是规则。他们会说一些话，比如，你知道，卓越在这个家庭中很重要。你想取得什么样的成功？或者我们真的很关心我们的行为对他人的影响。你想在你周围的世界留下什么样的印记？当他们的孩子长大后，他们有一套非常清晰的指导原则。当别人不同意他们时，他们愿意坚持自己的立场。他们也想了很多，不仅是创造性的自我表达，而且说，我怎样才能做
If you study some of the America's most original architects and compare them with technically scaled but less creative peers, one of the things that happened in the families of the creative architects was their parents focused more on values than rules. And they would say things like, you know, excellence is important in this family. What kind of success do you want to achieve? Or we really care about our actions having an impact on others. What sort of mark would you like to make on the world around you? And when their kids grew up, they had a very clear set of guiding principles. They were willing to stand their ground when other people didn't agree with them. And they also thought a lot about not just creative self-expression, but saying, how can I do
一些对别人有用的事情？但为什么基于规则的行为不能产生与基于价值观的建议相同的结果呢？当你专注于家庭中的规则时，很多时候孩子学会了遵守它们，这意味着接受现状，本质上成为了一只优秀的绵羊。而当你转向价值观时，孩子们实际上必须为自己思考。这很有趣，作为父母，对吧？因为读完这项研究后，我不断地发现自己每次我们的孩子表现不好时都会说：“新规则！”然后意识到，不，
something that's useful to other people? But why is it that rules-based behavior doesn't produce the same thing as values-based advice? When you focus on rules in a family, a lot of times kids learn to follow them, which means accepting the status quo and essentially becoming an excellent sheep. And when you go to values, kids actually have to think for themselves. What's, you know, this is funny as a parent, right? Because after reading this research, I'm constantly catching myself every time our kids misbehaves saying, new rule! And then realizing, nope,
我们应该谈谈这个规则背后的价值是什么。给我一个最近发生的例子。好吧，我们坐在晚餐桌旁，我们的家庭价值观之一是尊重。所以我们喜欢他们在每个人吃完饭之前不要离开餐桌。他们开始起身，就像，
we should be talking about what's the value behind this rule. Give me an example where that's happened recently. All right, so we're sitting at dinner, and one of our family values is respect. So we like for them to not get up from the dinner table before everyone's done eating. And they start to get up and it's like,
不，你必须坐在你的座位上。然后我开始意识到，好吧，我需要说的是，这就是为什么这很重要。你知道，他们开始起身，就像，不，你必须坐在你的座位上。然后我开始意识到，好吧，我需要说的是，这就是为什么这很重要，对吧？这不是关于拥有规则，而是关于说，看，我们喜欢大家都坐在座位上的原因是因为我们希望每个人都能分享一顿美好的家庭餐。我们认为这是一个很好的方式，你知道，
no, you must sit in your seat. And then I start to realize, well, what I need to say is, here's why that's And you know, they start to get up and it's like, no, you must sit in your seat. And then I start to realize, well, what I need to say is here's why that's important to us, right? It's not about having the rules, about saying, look, the reason we like to all sit in our seats is because we want everybody to share a nice family meal. And we think that's a great way to have, you know,
互相尊重。所以我认为当你谈论原创性和创造力时，我们的社会有一种巨大的渴望，想要培养人，想要让员工具有原创性和创造力。原创性和创造力有缺点吗？是的，当然。几年前，巴里·施瓦茨和我写了一篇关于“过犹不及效应”的论文，我们基本上认为所有的力量和美德都像金发姑娘一样，你拥有的太多或太少都不行。
respect for each other. So I think when you talk about originality and creativity, there's a great hunger in our society to want to race people, to want to have employees, be original and be creative. Are there downsides to originality and creativity? Yeah, of course. A few years ago, Barry Schwartz and I wrote a paper on the too much of a good thing effect, where we basically argue that all strengths and virtues are like Goldilocks, where you can have too much as well as too little.
毫无疑问，原创性也可能是这样。风险之一是每个人都朝着不同的方向前进。先驱需要定居者，领导者需要追随者。如果每个人都是原创者，那么你就没有人来帮助实施你的想法。但我认为相反的情况风险更大。如果每个人都顺从，那么我们就失去了改善周围世界的伟大方法。我不希望人们顺从，这基本上是说，我会同意你的想法，即使我不相信它。
And there's no question that with originality that can be true. One of the risks is that you have everybody marching in a different direction. And pioneers need settlers, leaders need followers. If everybody's an original, then you don't have anyone to help implement your ideas. But I think the opposite is a greater risk. If everybody conforms, then we lose out on great ways to improve the world around us. And I don't want people to conform, which is basically saying, I will go along with your idea even though I don't believe in it.
我希望他们为自己思考，有时决定别人的想法值得追随。亚当·格兰特，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。非常高兴。这一集由卡拉·麦格克-艾利森制作，尼尔·特沃尔德协助。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩、哈斯·沙阿、托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔和阿迪蒂·班·勒穆迪。我们的监制是塔拉·博伊尔。
I want them to think for themselves and sometimes decide that other people's ideas are worth following. Adam Graham, thank you so much for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Such a delight. This episode was produced by Cara McGurk-Allison with help from Neil Tevold. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Hath Shah, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarelle and Aditi Ban Lemoudi. Our supervising producer as Tara Boyle.
本周我们的无名英雄是特蕾西·沃尔。特蕾西是前NPR同事，曾与我们《隐藏的大脑》团队的几个人一起工作。她一直是我们工作的伟大支持者，她对讲故事的热情确实具有感染力。谢谢你成为一个伟大的朋友和同事，特蕾西。如果你喜欢我们的U2.0系列，请与能从这些故事中受益的朋友和家人分享。下周我们将为您带来本系列的最后一集。它是关于一个我们都应该更经常使用的简单、不花哨的工具。如果那些检查清单在二战开始时没有整合到那个水平，那么可以合理地假设，由于那个原因，成百上千甚至可能是成千上万的生命将会丧失。
This week our unsung hero is Tracy Wall. Tracy is a former NPR colleague who worked with several of us here on the Hidden Brain team. She has been a great supporter of our work and her enthusiasm for storytelling is truly infectious. Thanks for being a great friend and colleague Tracy. If you're enjoying our U2.0 series, please share it with friends and family who could benefit from these stories. Next week we'll bring you our final episode in the series. It's about a simple, unflashy tool that we should all use more often. If those checklists had not been integrated to that level at the start of World War II, and it's reasonable to assume that many hundreds and probably thousands of lives would have been lost due to that.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
I'm Sean Carvey-Danton, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是肖恩·卡维-丹顿，这里是美国国家公共电台。本期节目暂无评论。点击逐字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。